and brian we have new details in an
officer-involved shooting from last week
it happened wednesday on las vegas
boulevard near sunset so metro telling
us it started at a gas station when a
car pulled up next to a patrol car a
woman got out and she started asking for
help police say while they were talking
to her the suspect who's now been
identified as 34-year-old manuel
martinez got out right here and started
firing at those officers they fired bart
back martinez was hit but then he
managed to run away was later found and
taken to the hospital
during the course of our investigation
detectives learned that martinez and the
woman who approached the officers used
to be in a dating relationship
but that relationship
ended last year
he went on to tell us that martinez had
asked the woman to drive him to the
hospital just before this incident but
she began to feel unsafe that's when she
looked for police for help pulled into
the gas station martinez now facing
several charges